[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and now the Super Bowl is set Chris Sims
is in his home kitchen vendrick and
myself are in bleacher report Patriots
Rams the rematch zooms how are the games
what's up how you doing I'm trending
come in
I mean it's Martin Luther King Day and
once I saw the train schedules and
everything he comes handy yeah the kids
you know all the trains are forever
there you know a surprise rain 7 degrees
in New York my nose haters were freezing
together it is it's unbelievable my kids
are home from school so once I started
to piece that together I'm sorry to pull
the I'm gonna stay at home hard but yeah
just Josh and me coming and doing the
damn thing uh well first where do you
want to start Rams Saints or Patriots
cheese yeah I mean I guess let's start
with the Rams
the Rams days right what was your watch
setup how did you watch the game oh I
mean I watched just right here in my in
my family room didn't even sit on the
cloud we actually made a fire Danielle
had some chips in case though no and I
love queso that would have been so great
I know it would have been if you were
here but you weren't invited so sorry I
was watching I was watching at Josh's
place with my brother that's awesome you
guys had a good time uh well I will say
we'll just start off then I guess with
Saints Rams that my everyone knows my
he'll turn towards the Saints fans that
I'm not going to dive into that just yet
but when they went up 13 nothing
combined what was it 13 nothing yeah 13
nothing in the first quarter but
combined with the pick early and all
that and how loud the stadium was yeah I
was just I was going I can't believe I
picked the Rams like what a dumb
decision and you were texting about the
whistles it turned into a full-blown
investigation on Twitter where Mike
Tirico had to chime in and said that he
hung out with the whistle guy before and
he has a god-given ability to make a
piercing whistle but I know I was
distracted almost the entire game
Oh I mean without a doubt I mean I'm not
even joking you with I would say five
out of the first ten plays of the game I
thought they were about to stop like I
didn't think the play was going to go
ahead I was hearing whistles like right
around the time of the snap you could
tell that there was a extra emphasis on
that whistle who was ever in the crowd
was hoping to make that happen I've been
in the situation first of all in Seattle
one year I can't remember what season it
was I want to say it was the opening
game of the 2007 season I was not
playing because I was still with my
spleen injury but there was a whistle
and the stands and the first few rows of
the Seattle Seahawks game and they were
blowing out us early and they blew it on
us to the point where our punter stopped
in the middle of a punch line yes and
the referees were smart enough to
realize at that time that there was a
whistle in the crowd and they let us
redo it but the game was going to be
lost they I believe scored on the first
drive now we got the ball back and we've
seen three now you're saying we for the
rims I love them no I was saying we for
the Buccaneers and oh yes the hawk thing
right and just explaining that and now
here we are gonna punt the ball and look
and you think oh my gosh they they block
the punt and here we go and we're gonna
get blown out of the stadium but no the
whistle was there and that was an issue
so that drove me crazy but I think the
big thing is that you said left go about
the game I mean I had the same of the
same thoughts I said you know damn Chris
I mean X's and O's are great and
watching film is great but you forgot
about that
you know McVeigh is still six years
younger than you and their quarterbacks
young and their running backs young and
they haven't been in this environment
before that was my first thought of the
game early is that the Rams were so
flustered yes by the crowd noise in the
moment Shaun McVeigh at the end of the
first quarter they're gonna run a pie at
the end of the first quarter and the
referee tells him that the quarter is
about to end and he looks up at the
clock and go and then you could tell he
tells golf to say I'll let the quarter
read Allen so that just shows you that
the environment was overwhelmingly loud
and crazy that even like a McVeigh was
overwhelmed at that point
but you know you know just a breeze on
that topic two more left go like call a
timeout on the fourth down when your
defense jumps outside you know gather
your team these are young tires you know
there's a third and seven with golf and
they're snapping the ball with one
second left on the play clock in the
first quarter call a timeout it's the
first quarter gather your team's
composure get everybody's you know
emotions and heads in check before you
dig yourself too deep in a hole but
ultimately their defense save them left
go I mean save them save them and then
big balls Shawn McVeigh I mean
grapefruits calling that fake pun change
the game just like it changed this
Sunday I got your Eagles I call like I
was in Josh's living room and here's the
fake like I know that I know that it's
it is a big balls move to do that when
he did it but if he didn't do it I would
have been more upset gosh it's saying
second quarter you're down 13 nothing
and you're punting you know if that's
not the time to do it there was never a
time to do it well I mean the game's
over if they don't they're gonna get
blown out of the gym I just think I
think that they're the same people that
were upset with Shawn McVeigh that he
kicked the field goal at the end were
the ones that were like oh yeah you
gotta do the fake punt they're like I
don't know I
you cannot give that ball back to the
Saints so it was a big play but also I
mean Johnny Hecker is better than one
starting knows I'm just kidding but that
may be a serious serious question I got
a 10 yard hold on I got a 10 yard out
and I got bortles and I got Hecker
who's getting it there better be I'm
being dead serious I mean I I really
think Hecker is going to get it they're
better les is not hyperbole the way he
threw that ball really was no I can't
believe we're going down this road right
now but yes look man we mean it
we stand up for punters yeah well they
got like wacker does either even like
okay like you might have called it sorry
it happened and that's that's kudos
because I certainly like was like oh my
gosh like this is trouble but I think
the big thing I you know took from that
play with the fake punt too is I've
never really seen that play where it's
like we're gonna trust our cutter putter
to throw like a fade stop out on the
outside like it wasn't even like they
ran like a real route likes fake the go
route put your foot in the ground and
come back to the ball that was what was
impressive out of the fact right left go
where the Rams were their defense was on
the field the whole first quarter so to
me that was the other big you had to
save your defense I thought what was
incredible that actually was the longest
pass for the Rams for nearly the entire
half that 12 yard pass by hacker yeah
that was that's incredible that's
incredible but I did think that was a
huge moment in the game and at least I
gave changed the momentum and gave the
Rams a fighting chance from that point
on one everyone was called in CJ
Anderson the fat running back and I'm
gonna be very honest I didn't realize he
was that chunky like not until the game
started going where I was like this
man's doing this for chubby dudes
everywhere and let me just confirm for
everybody
chubby dudes are the best dudes just
saying Joe yep are you are you jumping
in that are you saying you're a chubby
dude as well I went to the gym today and
I almost fell oh yeah it hurt but he
really is reminding me of who's the guy
I'm thinking of on the other Panthers
that was there
CJ mercy yeah he fumbled no he's
Jonathan's Stewart nope the other is
another guy we're missing I'm driving me
crazy oh it's a Tolbert Mike Todd yeah
was it Tolbert is that was yes he
fumbled it's like that similar body low
gravity can bounce off hits and always
makes the pile move but yeah I mean
let's go I mean there's obviously
something wrong with Todd Gurley because
he doesn't even seem upset but I'm
saying he was on the sidelines and he
and I was wondering if you could tell
the way he was swinging his leg what was
he trying to loosen up is it a hip
flexor hip hamstring maybe everything
all together I don't know but I am a
little concerned with Todd Gurley just
he's got two weeks now though yeah yes
he does have two weeks or hope
to help them but I just hope there's
nothing long-term I mean it's sounding
like this is something he's going to
have to deal with that there's a
constant fluid buildup in his knee and I
just hope it's not bone on bone and he's
something he's gonna have to get
microfracture surgery with but like
regardless though let go the defence
saved the freakin game for the Rams what
happened yeah well I mean early on this
is where my big theme for the game would
be this and any coach would say this
when you don't put a team away or you
have a chance to put a team away well
you know then you leave it into the
hands of the rest sometimes and
sometimes they [ __ ] you over you know
what I mean all right I don't want to
get it happen I don't want to get into
that just yet
I with the referees the right let's talk
first just like player by player and how
you thought they did camara
I think camara is the best weapon in the
NFL he's up there
I mean he's certainly an awesome
football player he's in a he's an
awesome football player that you know
again it's Shaun to Peyton time Sean
Payton offense where you know they know
how to move him around perfectly for
Sean Payton I've been in that offense of
course with Jon Gruden they have more of
a playbook for the tailback coming out
of the backfield than most teams in
football as far as getting them the
football that type of player hmm all
right I can't wait any more I want to
talk about the play the pass
interference it was sure it was what one
let me hear your thoughts yeah well my
thought is this first of all is they
obviously blew the play we know that it
was pass interference now I will say I
think it's more bang bang than we're all
gonna get credit for because now we've
all watched it in super super slow
motion and I do think some of the other
angles that we see if you just watch it
from the exact sideline version the TV
version you know from the sideline cut
it is a little a lot more bang bang than
when they show the end zone with the guy
right on the field version or the other
you know on the field look that they
have shown where yeah okay it's a super
slow motion it's obviously passed
interference we know that I get it that
was a missed call by the the the
referees there's no other way around
that now you know
at the same time you know just to talk
about the X's and O's part man Nick
Howell Roby Coleman should have
intercepted that that's just one thing
to say there he said well market yeah I
mean he was he was there he was confused
before the snap so that messed up the
the play in general there's so many
things to talk about off of this play
though I think so yes they blew that
opportunity and I understand that and
that's certainly they should feel
screwed this day and age but I'm not
going to be sit here and say like that's
the only thing that dictated the game or
that's the only thing that the referees
influenced the game you know I I don't
wanna sit here and stand for all
legacies were changed because McVeigh
and Gulf legacy was almost changed to
dry before when Gulf was face masked on
the play he scrambled on which would
have been first and goal at the one but
it wasn't so then they didn't get the
touchdown how to kick a field goal so
again that that gets lost in the shuffle
I'm just saying yes this is a tough
break for them but tough breaks happen
all the time in football it's just
unfortunate that this happened in the
NFC Championship game in one of the big
moments and let me just wrap it up with
this thought to Lefko just says were on
this because there's more we were going
to talk about the game but you know I of
course I was amazed with how well Drew
Brees handled it he was a true
professional after the game so was Sean
Payton I mean they really could have
gone you know off the edge and and you
know [ __ ] the whole NFL and the
referees and really gone ham on them
drew Brees I thought was unbelievable as
a role model just saying you know hey of
course this is tough to swallow but you
get breaks during the year other things
happen it's just weird that it happened
in this moment and this is there where
I'm wrapping it up let go I come home my
little boy is watching youtube
highlights of the games yesterday then I
come back in about three minutes later
and he's watching youtube highlights of
Pittsburgh Saints and they're showing
the two horrible pass interference calls
ever called on the pittsburgh steelers
against the New Orleans Saints I just
thought it was funny and ironic to go
Dan maybe that was like the bad football
karma I know that's not going to lessen
the taste and the bad taste and the
Saints
a fans mouths or anything like that but
it is just one of those things I look at
and of course to add to that moment to
if Sean Payton just ran the ball on
first now to ran the ball a second down
and ran the ball on third down the Rams
would have got the ball back with about
37 35 40 seconds left in the football
game
and not been able to do it but because
he made that mistake it also leads to
now you've left the game into the
referees hands where they clearly blew
the call I understand that the NFL needs
to make a statement but I'm not going to
sit here and just say that one play
dictated the whole game I understand
it's easy to do that because we can
quantify it with time and the field goal
but there's other calls and other plays
along the way where we could certainly
say no this also dictated the football
game in a lot of different directions so
our slobber no no I see so what you're
saying is first and 10 Drew Brees throws
incomplete short to Michael Thomas and
yeah and second and 10 I'll run for no
game for camara and in the pass right
and what's interesting is is LA didn't
even have to get off at IMAP because why
didn't New Orleans take a timeout with
155 let's take a timeout with 155 when
they had the ball you mean oh you know
what it's just wrong and NFL Jesus lla
took their two timeouts yeah that was
just him I was wondering why that
happened
League has said they're not gonna issue
a statement that was a pro football talk
scoop this morning that they're not
gonna talk about about the pass
interference I did see that the NFL
plans to study making it possibly
reviewable but then again P go what
about the Jared Goff facemask I'm gonna
be honest I didn't see any pass
interference I saw really good coverage
from nikhyl Roby Coleman shutting down
the Saints when they really could have
put the game away and I think it's it's
incredible now that in the last two
years the Minnesota miracle you know
this I guess I don't know I didn't see
it this mist pass interference and the
Saints are just they don't even get to
taste
super bowl-like that's the thing that's
incredible is the fact that they're
sitting there as the number one seed you
know it's the first time in 48 years
that to number one seeds lost in the
championship game and I just wow I am
just emotional for the Saints I hear
such a jerk for those fans to go through
such an incredible year and it just felt
the whole time that they were gonna win
I just feel I feel I got the guy that
said he's gonna stab you maybe karma
came back to get him well we have a new
update in the clubhouse let me go check
my Twitter mentions for other people
that have come at me when you look at
that to let go just so I could clarify
for people listening out there the
Saints did call the timeout after that
incompletion but it was because they
were going to deploy the clock remember
and they were going to go to a delay a
game and they had to call a timeout if
you if you remember correctly ran the
ball on second down and the Rams call
the timeout and then of course third
down was the controversial no pass
interference call which despite let go
being an agitator and a [ __ ] starter was
pass interference call but you're you're
a jerk the Saints fans your rubbish all
right Josh read this tweet NOLA sports
fan eight eight at NRG underscore three
one four at Adam left code name the time
and place dad bod promise I'll cave your
face in ooh
so the new leader in the clubhouse is a
guy saying that he's gonna cave my face
in but I'm gonna be honest
knows your body well the part that upset
me the most is that he referred to me as
a dad but you don't know me like that
Romo bod is different than a dad bod
yeah I'm gonna try I'm only kidding that
was blatant pass interference I couldn't
believe it happened Sean Payton took off
his trendy clear glasses to yell at the
ref by the way I almost bought glasses
like that and then I saw like a hipster
in Brooklyn wearing them and I said I
can't pull it off but apparently Sean
Payton can yeah I well I also thought
that drew breezes play got worse as the
went on I thought he he threw so many
balls late and where he didn't have zip
or he was throwing it behind a receiver
or short and I and then like the
interception like that can't be got
forgotten too and drew brees is an
incredible person but I felt that he
didn't have the zip at the end that he
really needed that that that pull that
ball to the receiver what it pretty much
hit in a kohlrabi in the back it was
going to he certainly was open before
that I said like I just don't think
there was a lot of Drew Brees pass at
the end that didn't have the zip
necessary well I I mean to listen I
think that's fair I mean again you know
he is up there and aged he still awesome
and does things so yes he's not going to
allow us with his you know B ability to
push balls into tight windows and things
like that I think what we got to do
really more than anything what's getting
lost in this whole conversation is the
Rams defense is phenomenal
they held the New Orleans Saints to 290
total yards they made the run game of
the New Orleans Saints non-existent they
made Michael Thomas who went for 212
yards the last time non-existent and I'm
excited to watch that film and what are
your what are your first thoughts as to
how that happened well I think first of
all I mean it's C it's games like this
and I'm gonna start open up a can of
words like this is where I just look at
Michael Thomas and go no he's not a
number one receiver
I mean he's a number one receiver but
he's not like top five in football I
don't care what his stats say again his
his greatest ability is the fact that
Sean Payton puts him in spots where his
defense has a hard time stopping him you
know he's not the type of receiver you
can line him outside like Antonio Brown
or Odell Beckham jr. or Julio Jones all
game and say we expect you to beat the
best corner covering you all game on he
can't do that that's not what he does he
needs to be moved around to a degree and
there was obviously attention paid to
him all the time and certainly when he
ran shallow crossers for the most part I
felt like there was guys there to watch
over him they a changed looks when he
was in the slot and did stuff like that
as well I thought but I don't know
exactly what they did to him that's
where I'm excited to watch on film in
general yeah but I just do think that
the Rams played special on
defense for the second week in a row
because why they're playing it close to
the vest like I think we've both seen
the last few weeks where they don't do a
whole lot because they have phenomenal
talent and domercant sue had us do this
game this year I was just gonna say
there's been a players on the Rams that
in these last two games have exploded
back on the scene Dante Fowler in
downtown Sioux Marc Baron like those
three guys now now they've gotten burned
a few times because they're in some
tough positions but those three guys
were making plays man yes I mean that's
why I mean the Cory Littleton sorry he
was all over and around and yeah right
and I think that's the big thing like I
think it goes back to like a little what
we were saying last week where you know
since Sioux and Donald's are playing it
more by-the-book up front it's allowing
Baron Littleton to be more ball Hawks
they're not having to worry about oh
this is my gap oh wait Aaron Donald's
shot into my gap now I had to cover his
gap you know what I mean that's that's
what has happened to some of those those
players at times barren and Littleton
now where they're playing it close to
the vest the two guys up front they're
free to go with I know exactly where I
need to be and if the balls not there
then I can go just get the ball carrier
and it's shown some of their explosive
ability but you're right - dude I mean
soo Dante Fowler again the Rams
their defense it was a big-time strain
and pressuring the quarterback well and
it's interesting like I'm honestly
rewatching the game right now just to
kind of watch the lines and the pushes
and stuff
the Rams really had a clean pocket for
golf the Saints as you said we're
missing that other pass rusher Davenport
wasn't able to do it in this first year
and then losing rankings was so big but
every time I'm seeing Drew Brees drop
back there are a few white gloves
clawing at his arms that they're getting
the push
yes I you know I I guess and as a truth
football fan and again I'm not trying to
be a hater on the Saints fans or Saints
or anything like that so please don't
take it that way anybody out there
that's rooting for the Saints but I do
think the better team won the football
game I think that's why I can
swallow the crappy non-call at the end
better than I can call her better than
maybe if he was wide open and the guy
was trailing behind him and had to pull
his jersey to stop them you know what I
mean like I guess as a football player I
can look at that play also just go man
the X's and O's were there to be stopped
but I think the big thing to let go that
we can't like neglect in this and it's
the overriding like thesis of this whole
thing here is this why the [ __ ] is the
NFL officiated differently in the
playoffs than it is in the regular
season that's the biggest problem the
NFL has here because all year long I
mean that would have been a pass
interference and [ __ ] I don't know the
guy might have been ejected for
headhunting who the hell knows but isn't
you know I know people also are wanting
that defenseless receiver we haven't
seen defenseless receiver called all
playoffs it's not going to be called
because the referees are too afraid of
being the showcase in the football game
so they've let the players play and this
was a moment where they wanted to let
the players play and they tried to keep
their hands in their pockets but this
one was you know egregiously wrong where
it just you do have to just call that at
that moment and go on hey look my team
won the Super Bowl last year because
they let us play like yeah like think
about it all those plays that the Eagles
got last year where they decided not to
overturn the play in plays that were
being overturned all year like the Cory
Clement catch in the back of the end
zone it was exactly like the Austin
Safari and Jenkins incompletion I have
it happens in every sport I feel like
the strike zone changes in the playoffs
I feel like MBA fouls are called
differently in the playoffs all right
you know it's it's a different game in
the playoff I do want to give credit cam
Jordan did have a big sack and cam is a
phenomenal player and he doesn't get
enough credit but the guy that I think
we didn't give credit to a long time
made an incredible roll out throw on
third down with nine minutes left in the
game Jared Goff rolling out against the
grain findin Gerald Everett Jared Goff
played a good game not a big fan of him
his time management at the end and the
way he kind of threw that incompletion I
feel like he got scared and said I'm
just gonna give the ball to Gregg the
leg but I thought das played a great
game I am would you love God he did play
a great game yeah I mean yes I mean I I
think if he doesn't panic there again
you're gonna have Robert Woods over the
middle on the route that we saw him
complete earlier in the drive that he
kind of threw in accurate easy where is
that what you thought happened to I
thought he looked around and was like I
can't take a sack and I'm a little bit
afraid so I'm just gonna dead this ball
and let's bring out the kicker I I think
all of that played into it he understood
that he's got it he couldn't take that
sack I think when he saw the pressure
off the edge he wasn't sure if he was
picked up schematically and he was not
gonna risk it so he just got the ball
out of his hands but yeah I mean there's
certainly a play there to be had going
across the middle which I you know in
the West Coast office we called it a
lookie-lookie where the receiver has the
option to go go inside if it's there to
be had and then and if he gets cut off
inside he pushes inside like he's gonna
run that route and then he retraces back
outside and that was there to be had but
to your point Jared Goff so many so many
big throws I mean really was I mean you
talk about some of the plays he made
right before the half to go down and
make the game 1310 but the fade route
down the left sideline Brandon cooks yes
right that was a huge moment another
another deep throw before the facemask
that wasn't called to Keenan Reynolds
that was a nice touch ball exactly right
that was a great ball as well and then
really your play that you're discussing
where he scrambled out to his right and
found Gerald Everett was probably the
play of the game for Jared Goff but yes
for them again to battle back in the way
they were down 20 to 10 in that
environment I just can't get enough
credit to that team McVeigh everybody
for just hanging in there and and
dealing with an environment and
experience that you know of course they
were very new to all right so it's easy
to take the blame off the Saints and by
saying that the P I was missed
but when Ted Ginn caught that deep ball
with two minutes left that brought them
down to the 12 yard line and the Rams
had two timeouts you're absolutely right
why are you throwing on four
first why are you why are you throwing
on third why are you throwing under like
underneath screen passes to Michael
Thomas you have alvin kamara
and you have Ingram like waste the clock
like wait the clock you cuz I I as
someone that bet on the Rams I was
rooting for the Rams when Ted Ginn got
that ball and we went to commercial I
went right it was a great game
23:20 Saints it's over so so we could
get angry about the missed call on third
down but the Saints you know were
yelling at the Falcons when Kyle
Shanahan threw the ball on first and
third and he should have ran it three
times in that game
situational football I grabbed that's
all I get again that's what I mean so
and and then like you know again we're
time I know we're gonna come off as
Saints haters no matter what but we did
I was college straight well yeah that's
what we try that's what we do that's
exactly right I know and it just it just
it's tough hey listen I feel for the
same I really did this is two years in a
row of like the most gut-wrenching
[ __ ] losses ever like I said this to
Josh okay I said this to Josh yesterday
I said two years ago Sims said I don't
know what it is I'm looking at the
Saints roster and the Saints can make a
run at a Super Bowl and I said yesterday
you know what Sims kind of called the
the start of this run and if they the
Saints go to the Super Bowl this year I
could totally see them winning it and I
feel like Sims kind of called it two
years ago we the Saints are perfectly
built they have guys on the backend that
can cover people they have athletic
linebackers they got a few monsters up
front and cam Jordan and Sheldon
rankings when healthy that can really
push a pile they have a great offensive
line with multiple weapons at wide
receiver running back that can play all
the positions a quarterback that can
execute a game plan that the game plan
is so special because the coach is
perfect they have an insane home-field
advantage and they play in a division
which the bottom falls out every year
and the Super Bowl was in a dome they
were the team I told everybody before
the year the two teams that were really
interesting from a betting perspective
were the Saints eighteen to one and the
Steelers 1801 and I think also the
Chargers were around eighteen to twenty
to one
they're a Superbowl quality team that
had all the pieces together and it just
didn't happen but I will say this Saints
fans the Eagles were up 14 and nothing
on the Saints the game didn't come down
to a player 2 at the end that didn't go
our way why did we run up and throw that
ball to Al Shean no it came at when it
was 14 enough and we didn't put our foot
on their throat right you didn't kill
the team and they didn't kill the team
when when Miranda when the Rams held the
Saints to a second field goal to go up 6
nothing I said we got ourselves a game
because that you need to score
touchdowns there when you're up 13
nothing you need to put them away yeah
yeah I mean there was that that really
to me that's why I we you know we
started off talking about the Rams
defense their ability to hold the the
Saints the two field goals early and
really be a team that was overwhelmed in
the game and all we'd be down 13 nothing
that was the game in my eyes
certainly it really was because yeah
that I think on a normal day versus most
teams in the NFL the New Orleans Saints
are up 17 nothing there I'm 21 nothing
and it's just like oh it's the Avalanche
there at the Superdome this is over
there's no way this other team can
compete today but their defense kept
them in the football game and because of
that yes it gave them a chance to kind
of get their feet underneath them get
used to the circumstances and and at the
end of the day like we were talking
about with Sean Payton throwing that
ball on first down you know again I just
can't tell you how many times I've been
in a you know on this type of loss or
you know a loss where it was dictated by
some bad penalty call or whatever and we
go we just look at each other and go
damn I mean we should have just we
should have known better we should have
never left it in the rest hands we had
chances to end this game early and
really and that's where they're gonna
kick themselves of course they're gonna
it's gonna hurt because of the missed
pass interference call but as true
football competitors they're going to go
back and watch that film and go man this
should have not even been in a game we
could have we should have put this away
to where it never got too
yeah so I thought them not putting it
away them not ending the game late was
issues right there by the Saints and
then you see the beauty of Shaw
mcveigh's offense on that last Drive by
Jared Goff to tie it up where it's third
and three on the Saints 49 and he stacks
cooks and woods on the left and he he
puts them right on top of each other and
woods just goes right underneath because
it's an inadvertent pick and he picks up
the amount of yardstick feel to feel
comfortable for Greg and I thought Shawn
was unbelievable
I thought he handled himself so well
with his play calls I felt like he
really created what we always asked for
which is plays to go off of each other
the with the use of the play-action the
use of the stretch runs into Jared
Goff's ability especially on turf to
kind of find those mismatches on the
other side and I don't know about you
when I saw Shawn McVeigh getting
interviewed after the game and he said I
don't know about that but I got a little
baby I was like John Byrne's back in the
Superbowl back he is when he talks he's
Jon Gruden he's at night he looks like
the only difference is Shawn McVeigh is
going to hit the potential that John
Gruden's ego wouldn't let him hit that's
my honest it's my true feeling he's my
area that's a good take it's a good
feeling when I look Josh said this
yesterday when you look at pictures of
Shawn McVeigh and his fiancee or
girlfriend or wife I'm not exactly sure
what she is it looks like like an
advertisement for a real estate agent in
Malibu it looks too perfect they look
plastic but what's funny is is that
Shawn McVeigh Shawn McVeigh irons his
khakis and he irons his polos and he
tucks it in and he goes to work every
day and he comes up with the scheme and
the problem is is Gruden I think
eventually read all his press clippings
McVeigh goes I don't have time to read
yeah and I guess this could be do you go
there I think that's the biggest thing
what you're saying less ego Shawn
McVeigh's willing to you know Melissa
- Oh Wade Phillips and let him have
control the defensive game plan Shaun
McVeigh's willing to steal plays from
other people in the NFL and not be
ashamed to admit it or whatever it may
be and thus those little things - why
yeah he's the man and of course and the
youngest coach in Super Bowl history
man it's hey look look what were you
saying
I would say last thing about the Saints
moving on to moving forward because I
know we're gonna get ready to talk about
this next game after this is just to me
one thing that was jumped out to me
about the Saints just that I do think
they have to address this offseason they
need one more weapon in the in the past
game you know yeah I think really what
came back to hurt them more than
anything is the Rams could put all their
eggs in there let's stop Michael Thomas
let's try to contain Alvin Kamara in the
past game and we should be okay from
there and of course camara had a good
day but I think they were willing to
live with 11 catches for 96 yards and
not be you know 11 catches 160 yards or
something like that but they do need
that one other weapon to where teams
can't focus on their main weapons so
much in certain formations and take them
away yeah I think would you look at
their roster and how it was constructed
they come in to the gate to the year and
Mike Thomas Ted Ginn got hurt for a
while and he he did not look like the
Ted Ginn in the last few years when he
did get by guys like in the Eagles game
he'd lose the ball in the lights he
wasn't that reliable I thought tre Quan
Smith played a really good year but do
you know what guy I think hurt them the
most I really think the Saints entered
this year expecting a lot out of Cam
Meredith and we never saw him I think
that was a they they paid a lot more
than people thought for that for Cam
Meredith and I never sold a production
and he got hurt but it was like the
Tommy Lee Lewis's and did you agree with
with Troy that putting in what's our guy
the quarterback Haytham hell did you
agree with Troy that putting in Taysom
Hill was was hurting breezes flow I
can't say that I felt that way no I I
did not have totally agree
with that I mean yeah I just feel like
David listen that's been a part of their
offense all year long I was expecting
more of a taste and he'll package really
in the football game I really was I
thought we would see him with some more
quarterback design runs or you know last
week what they did is they had
quarterback design rpoS where he was
running the toss sweep to the right but
also could throw the ball down the field
as he was looking at is there lanes to
run the ball I thought we were gonna see
more of that it was really actually a
little shocked we didn't see a few more
you know creative wrinkles from that
aspect from the same man but overall the
Saints had an opportunity with the first
possession of overtime to go down drew
Brees
you know this is what happens sometimes
with Drew Brees pressure in his face
ball flutters in the air intercepted and
the Rams are able to get like one or two
first downs and then kick a 57-yard
field goal they're going to the
Superbowl do we have the right
representative for the NFC in your mind
were the Rams the best team that skill I
still feel like the Saints were the
better team I know that you said the
better team was yeah that's okay
it was very close so you know it was
extremely close football game and I I
totally understand your feeling of that
as well yeah I think at the end of the
day I do feel like the Rams were better
but I certainly respect you know you
sang the Saints or anybody else saying
the Saints it was that close and of
course we saw how close it really was
but for me in both games I thought the
best team won and but it is a shitty way
for the Saints and I can't even imagine
what they feel like this morning because
good this is the type of loss that if
you're Drew Brees like he's gonna wake
up in certain days when he's 73 years
old and he's gonna go damn there's I
mean I just can't believe we lost that
game like it's gonna still hit home to
him like it's still to get the day after
the game and random days twenty and
thirty years from now and that's what
happens when you're an elite athlete and
you have some big-time losses like this
and I just want you to know the Saints
locker room right now is furious there's
been a petition signed by hundreds of
thousands of Saints fans Michael Thomas
has been very active he literally just
tweeted hey
Roger pick up the phone so they're all
calling for a rematch and I think it's
it's interesting like it's man it feels
like they're their Super Bowl trip has
been taken away from them two years in a
row in a weird way
yeah but the I think it was bleacher
report put it out put out a picture for
the Rams of all the big-name free agents
and money they spent so it was like
kendama can sue and and they traded it
for Dante Fowler and they paid all this
money for Aaron Donald and all these
things franchise LaMarcus Joyner you
know that's got to keep to Levi me a
name they saw it say Josh to make it
happen and kudos to them so we commented
underneath that post like you got to
spend money to make trophies and what
did Le'Veon Bell comment under that
photo also because you know Levien's got
gotta get involved which is phenomenal
left go PR to find his way there but
what did he say so levy on under the
post wrote exactly what you're supposed
to do they did it right forget trying to
save for the future you better go and
try and win that [ __ ] right now when you
can yeah yeah yeah all right you ready
you wanna go to the other game yeah I
can't believe I can't it's just I'm
still coming to grips with the fact that
there's one NFL game left I'm coming to
grips with the fact that a team like the
Saints are dead
you know like anyway that's a weird yeah
the you know when I look back I always
you know I say this about Hall of Famers
that you have to tell the story the
Saints were one of the the top two
stories in my mind like both of the
teams that lost yesterday the Saints and
the Chiefs all year it felt like a
collision course of those two teams and
I I do feel a little bit robbed of that
narrative yeah that's a Super Bowl
matchup as a fan I wanted to watch the
most I mean I know I picked the other
two teams to win but I wanted to see
Chiefs
Saints there's a true fan that was the
game I wanted to watch on TV more than
anything yeah I think I thought that
that one was going to give us the best
blend of coaches that were gonna leave
it all out there with quarterbacks that
can execute their system
and then right and and just no fear no
I'm the storylines and all of it yes all
it all would have been yeah I I'm with
you left go I think that would have been
the best storylines all maybe this means
we get Pat mahomes now at our at Dan
Tana's in Atlanta again email soon as a
left got Gmail maybe Patrick my homes
are gonna be there I don't know put that
on a flyer maybe Patrick my homes will
be there alright let's get to this game
so we watch the first game at Josh's
place and then we went to a bar
downstairs with my brother to watch the
second game it's just such a different
experience to watch in a bar you know
there there are there are plays let's
say the muffed punt where we were going
nuts for eight seconds afterwards but
everyone at home knew it seems like the
MVP of this game though was Tony Romo
everyone he was pretty awesome Wow were
you that was my first question for you
was when he was calling Edelman over the
middle element over the middle grok on
the outside were you seeing the same
thing or was Romo just on it no I mean
Romo was on it but yes certainly I mean
no you know if you watch New England the
most and you know I think you can attest
that I'm a pretty avid watcher of New
England I regular basis I would say
they're the only film that I can
guarantee on a weekly basis you're
guaranteed to watch I would agree with
that there's no matter what it is I am
going to sit down at some point and
watch New England because they're gonna
do things that you know I haven't
thought of or other teams didn't do to
attack this team and I always find that
really intriguing when you break them
down but yes I mean you know just the
way they attack in general Romo was all
over it I mean he he knew where they
were gonna run the football he
understood what they were trying to do
when they were dropping back to pass so
that was that was fun to watch a few
times ago he's gonna check at this side
he's gonna check the run this side and
you know by god damn it they went to
that side and ran the ball and got her
first down so that was cool but I mean
as much as Romo was awesome damn the
freakin Patriots just once again just
show the X's and O's beat the jimmies
and the Joe's that's really all that
comes down to to me
Simms if Tony Romo can predict
every play why can't Bob Sutton well you
know there's rain worries out there
certainly I know and it's a lot easier
to just predict where they might work
once you're seeing the team lineup and
you get to see the matchup right so you
know it's different than calling a
defensive play in the huddle and going
well Dan when during this personnel set
there's like 25 different plays I have
to worry about here or 25 different
schemes I got to worry about with this
personnel set Tony Romo gets the
advantage of seeing it lined up and then
going oh ok they've lined up they've
stressed the Chiefs out here I know that
when they get in this formation they
might like this matchup here or you know
or they're going to look across at all
the matchups and Tony Romo is gonna get
the benefit that Bob Sutton does go and
go all well the Patriots you know like
the favor of this matchup because also
New England's probably told them some of
the things they like during you know the
pre meeting things and so he's alert to
what could look for also knowing what
the Patriots do in certain situations
according to what the defense that has
been called on the field and now he gets
to see a lineup that's where it's
different than being the defensive
coordinator on the sidelines alright so
this is a good answer Josh was that all
right yes it was thank you yeah I think
the I can thank Josh I think the thing
that everyone underestimates with color
commentators and broadcasters is the
amount of questions and information that
you get before the game that influences
the way in which you call the game sure
yes I I think that's a very valid point
I don't think you're getting a ton of
information from New England no but
you'll at least get a feel for how they
feel where they match up good in certain
areas and things like that and having
watched games with you before and other
quarterbacks because I do believe this
is a quarterback trait you guys are able
to see you guys are able to retain
formation usage and use that for keys
yes without a doubt formation formation
usage and then I think what the one
thing quarterbacks can always do is go
no matter what the formation is or who
the players are
I've watched New England and I
when the defense plays this defense they
like to attack this area that's where I
can like sum it up sometimes just go oh
okay yet Edelman in the slot or it's
Hogan in the slot all but when the
defense does this and the Patriots in
this formation they're gonna try to
expose this area I've watched enough to
know that this game went so well in the
Patriots way that it's like if you
played this a hundred times this would
be in like the 98th percentile of how
you'd want it to go as a Patriots fan 14
nothing at halftime here are the total
stats for the game okay yeah the
Patriots had five hundred and twenty
four net yards Kansas City had 290 the
Patriots ran ninety-four offensive plays
the Chiefs ran forty seven amazing
Patriots had a hundred and seventy-six
rushing Chiefs had 41 Patriots had 348
passing Chiefs head to 49 yeah um in
terms of time of possession the Patriots
had the ball for 44 minutes the Chiefs
had it for 21 yep it was everything that
we've said about these teams coming to
life the Patriots are a running football
team Sonne Michele gets 29 carries the X
Factor for the Chiefs is Sammy Watkins
four catches 114 including what I
believe was the fake punt of this game
which was the third and two mahomes over
the top to walk it right which sparked
sparked the Chiefs that was that was the
play that woke them up that was really
the hit play no doubt but that first
half was just an absolute bludgeoning
Sims a bludgeoning again but just like
the first game weekend man this game
should be 21 nothing or something worse
but Brady throws of course the bad
interception on the second Drive of the
game when they're on the one-yard line
the 1 foot line see from me that was
that was an even trade you had the Brady
pick which equaled mahomes on the
running back wheel route overthrow yeah
okay we're late were then later he was
and it caused a pun for me that that
game should have been 21 to 7 so being
14 to nothing was the same yeah I don't
know if you can go tic for tack there
you can't go with a guy missing a
receiver and hoping it he'll see he's
like captain clutch throwing in one of
the dumbest interceptions in the history
of his career why is that now you're
saying why is that route still a thing
on the one-yard line the dump over the
middle where there's a million defenders
yeah well I you know again New England
doesn't do anything that was the
Pittsburgh interception to Denver well a
little bit you're exactly right but you
know what happens to quarterbacks in
that case personalized in Kansas City
did something that they weren't
expecting in that moment I think they
thought you know Kansas City would sell
out for the inside runs like like New
England had done and you know they
stopped New England on a 4th and 1 let's
not forget about that the fourth quarter
but I think they were they were
expecting such a sell out there that
they would just have somebody wide open
over the middle and I'm sure did wide
open and practice all week that's why
Brady kind of came up like nonchalantly
like oh this will be wide open it and
they dropped people out of the line of
scrimmage is what it looked like to me
and again I'll have better answers for
everybody when we do our film breakdown
on Wednesday but yeah that was a you
know of course a huge part of the
football game and of course gave the
Chiefs life because you go down 14 nuts
in there you're starting to go oh yeah
this is going to snowball but at the end
of the day I mean hey if we were going
to sum this whole thing up again it's
just like it's it's Bill Belichick team
football against one guy in mahomes
trying to make magic happen and our
worst nightmare came true for Kansas
City as usual oh wait oh you know what
happens when they lose the game is their
defenses on the field last and you know
everything everybody's got their
kryptonite or their weakness or it's
going to get exposed at some point
exciting the only a traditional moment
right and it's the 31st ranked defense
in football and they finally met a game
plan that had the people up front to
slow down the great pass rush we never
even heard d4 door Justin Houston or
Christian
throughout the game they were they were
non-existent so England with the run
game of play-action just absolutely
flustered the Kansas City Chiefs and and
there wasn't a whole lot they could do
when Chris Jones got hurt in the fourth
did he stay out after that I feel I you
know because I'm looking look here he
came back in for a few snaps here and
there but I play wrong
he played 51 of the 97 snaps for 50% I
can't imagine that Chris Jones played
that few snaps all year I wouldn't think
so you're exactly right that's that
Justin Huston played 95
he played 98 percent of the snaps Alvin
Bailey played 80 percent naughty played
60% deep word word I'm looking D Ford
played 84 percent so yeah Chris Jones
playing 53 percent is the equal of
Fletcher Cox against the Saints no doubt
about because its enormous because then
you know Rex Burkhead might get banged
up at the line instead of getting 5
yards and no touch well you could get
batted footballs like we saw him do
early in the game or you got his hand up
on a big third down I believe or a third
and so either way but yeah I mean to
your point Chris Jones is the best yeah
other than you could you know all those
investigation mahomes like Chris Jones's
he's in the top five players of that
football team and he's the best player
on their defense there's no even denying
that that is the star player of the
Kansas City Chiefs defense and they rely
on that front for ruining games yes and
of course they weren't enabled to ruin
the game they didn't get one sack they
led football in fact this year and
they're here's a game where they never
really had the opportunity to get by
ever or get close to Tom Brady because
McDaniels
is a top 5 play caller every guy had
cushions and bubbles and the ball was
out so quickly and you know what's great
man the Patriots are just so damn
consistent it's a game in which Brady
throws for 3:48 Edelman and Gronk are as
leading receivers and a running back
that came out of nowhere is now their
leading rusher it's every year it's
every year
Brady one touchdown two interceptions
still win the game yeah that's right I
mean and just ahead of the curve just
like we always talked about doing I know
we're gonna make it transition from our
41 year old you know maybe greatest
quarterback in the history of the sport
certainly the most decorated we know he
can't carry the team like he could back
you know five six years ago so we got to
become a running football team we're
gonna stop drafting old linemen we're
gonna draft a first-round tail but
tailback and we're gonna win games that
way so we're also our 41 year old
quarterback doesn't have to get beat to
death rolling the ball 50 times a game
because he won't last that way it's just
New England on another level and then
really at the other thing we got to talk
about again I mean just like the other
game you know with we gotta bleep raise
the Rams the good new England Patriots
defense held the greatest show we've
seen in football the last few years to
290 total yards of offense
there was no consistency right from from
the Chiefs really an offense it was
really just oh I mean my Holmes is gonna
have to make a big play oh my Holmes is
gonna have to scramble out to the right
and throw a 40-yard dart to the tailback
up the sideline with no angle to throw
it but he'll throw it perfectly I mean
that's what one team was relying on and
then meanwhile the other team was you
know against in their advanced
hieroglyphics class where they have
doubled Tyree kill all game long any
time there's a passing situation Stephon
Gilmore he stuck on Sammy Watkins for
the most part
JC Jackson would go on Kelsey sometimes
JC Jackson and Gilmore switched to where
JC jacksonland Watkins and Gilmore won
Kelsey but just another masterful game
plan and something they didn't do the
first two times they're the last two
times they played the Chiefs they didn't
they didn't approach it that way and I
bet you did caught the Chiefs by
surprise and we talked about again left
go right with like my Holmes and his
ability to scramble well they limited
his scrambling for the most part all
night and they compared he's 11 yards
right right and you know that was the
big worry for me for the game was you
know if they keep my homes in the pocket
can he beat them I can't even lie I was
shocked that we
we were I was sitting there going I
can't believe the Chiefs are still in
this game really I really couldn't you
know just like the Saints I felt like
should have put away the Chiefs I went
man
the Patriots should have put away the
Chiefs this game should be over they're
gonna get their ass burned here now
because my home is gonna make some play
and win this football game fortunately
for them it didn't happen and they found
a way to win the game so I went on
next-gen stats because I was curious how
many of Brady's 30 completions for 348
were over 10 yards yeah 30 completions I
just did the knight 23 of the 30 where
10 yards or less yeah 19 were 5 yards or
less right 19 of Tom Brady's 30
completions were 5 yards or less now all
three of his touchdowns were over 10
yards and I feel pretty confident that
they were all play action based well
yeah your your Brady only threw one
touchdown so oh excuse me just getting
that straight but either way a mislabel
they mislabeled his other interceptions
as touchdowns on next got you got you
yeah so like yeah I mean hey this is
what New England does they're not gonna
they're not gonna ask Brady to be
Patrick Holmes and throw you know
40-yard lasers all over the field all
game long but when asked to and the
biggest moment Brady threw the ball
phenomenal just like he did last week so
let's say let's just get to this yeah
it's over time three third and tens and
those guys were not open man like the
beautiful thing like I think Drew Brees
has another season in him yeah I think
Tom Brady has another five I really do
like he it's a master class of the front
in the profession and they're there at
such a level now and also the offenses
and the game plans that are built to
route them around them allow them to
execute and not have to do it by
themselves this isn't this isn't Randall
Cunningham this isn't John Elway you
know these guys like
this is why Payton could keep playing
the game but Payton didn't have an
offensive mind at the end to make it
easier for him no lose the arm that's
the one thing don't forget about that
brain Rayleigh still has the arm Brady
does brandy has so much more armed than
Brees but it really is incredible that
they're at a level of reading defenses
now and they're at a level two of Brady
so much more than Brees of knowing what
it takes to win and being calm in that
moment it's the reason we're amazed by
Nick Foles because you know foals has
that and we're going you're not Tom
Brady Tom Brady makes sense because he's
got five Super Bowl rings and no one can
touch him and he's incredible but made
it incredible but he gets out there in
overtime and there wasn't a doubt I
never had a doubt and I'm gonna give
credit to Fender ik so the fourth down
stop by the Chiefs right fender o'clock
Sammy and ghosts Patriots are winning
this game when the Patriots got stopped
on fourth down and they showed Belichick
and balichek didn't look faced Fenric
went the Patriots are one in this game
now we had a few more we had a few more
lead changes but the whole time fed ryx
going no Patriots are one in this game
yeah so I'm gonna give him credit yeah I
felt the same way as you did Josh I
really did I kept going there one in
this game did the better team and I get
going man unbelievable I mean oh my gosh
Kansas and he made another big play my
homes at holy cow they're still hanging
in here
I kept thinking the same thing clearly
hey there was a better more complete
football team and let's go to your point
about Brady I mean it's like it's
unbelievable I mean him him driving down
at the end of the AFC Championship game
he must feel like most quarterbacks feel
like preseason game number three that's
how numb he must be to that moment at
this point like Oh AFC Championship game
game-winning drive no problem I've been
there for the Superbowl this is my
eighth time doing isn't a Super Bowl
where I got to go on the game-winning
drive AFC Championship I mean geez
please don't even waste my time with
boiling my blood on the
one I mean that's how amazing it is what
New England is doing it is the greatest
dynasty we have ever seen in any sport
ever what they're doing we will never
see anything like this ever again
as much as we want to hate the New
England Patriots and I understand it I
was rooting for the Kansas City Chiefs I
thought yesterday as that game was going
on but as the game went on left go I
just kept going no I'm gonna root with
the Patriots because they're better and
they deserve it and if I was wanting it
I did I was not I'm sitting there I'm
sitting there watching that ball go over
Julian Edelman fingers and I'm in this
bar go and it touched his thumb you bet
your ass it touched his thumb which that
play was an optical illusion it was it
really who was I I do think they got it
right because we do not yet every part
where I felt like you where I was like
oh it looked like they touched it and
this might a touch this part the other
camera angle where you're like oh no it
didn't even come close to that part so
all right how do our boy how did our boy
Emma Holmes play overall I mean he
played okay overall I mean I really
think he did about as much as he could
do he missed a few throws like you
talked about he missed at you know a
touchdown pass Tim you know who is that
yes right - Damian Williams he took the
the bad sack when they were in field
goal range yes you know that was another
young moment but again you know hey it's
the guys 23 years old and he's got
nothing else around him helping him
there's no run game they become
one-dimensional they're gonna drop back
and throw the football yes they hammer a
re Kelsey they have cam Irving starting
on their offensive line yeah I mean it
just it just is all it was it was top t
they met you know the ultimate team that
we've seen in team sports and they had a
great game plan for keeping him in the
pocket look at some of the things they
did with their defensive line right they
kept running these n tackle games where
the end would crash inside to basically
create the inside pressure writing the
time as we go the outside today would go
outside right to contain him then to go
nope you're staying
this pocket we're gonna crash it right
in your face Wow and then we're gonna
have somebody there waiting for you on
the edges when you try to get outside
and make mahomes magic and they made
life very uh thoughtful
we saw was relegated to really only one
guy getting off and that was Sammy
Watkins and I think we've seen all year
that when only one guy gets off in
Kansas City they have issues it's
happening in two and three guys off that
sounded there we go uh I think what's
incredible is they didn't just hold
Tyreke l21 catch for 42 yards they held
him to three targets right like they
didn't even I never even saw throws
going to Tyree killed was there anything
that you saw from the broadcast that
that you saw what they were trying to do
was it just like every time it was it
was looked like it was Jonathan Jones
underneath I McCourty over the top a lot
of the times or maybe it was Jason
McCourty underneath and the other you
know in Devon and Devon's back deep
enough but what they did more times than
not is just cancelled them out of
mahomes thought process before the play
even started and that's what I thought
is I just kept going
he's got man-to-man on Sammy how is he
not right look at that yeah I yeah yeah
exactly it took a while for them to
figure out their game plan and that's
where I go
I don't think Kansas City was expecting
that type of game plan or I think maybe
Andy Reed would have moved around Tyree
kilmore you know there's ways you can
stress a team when they want to do
double coverage and things like that but
they never really got into a flow of
trying to find him the football and the
homes being the young quarterback he was
he sees double-team before the snaps
he's got another one and that's all
there was to it but it was just
masterful game planning once again and
New England's built for the modern day
NFL they just they're go we're going to
get really good cover guys we're going
to do some creative things and then
we're going to have like you said a
million times and we talked about alas
week all these all-purpose guys up front
to where you don't know who's Blitzen
who's dropping out when we get in you an
obvious passing situation and if we're
not sure if it's maybe a you could run
or throw it
well [ __ ] we're just going to put three
gigantic
guys in the middle and try to slow it
down that way and we'll just cover you
on the back end and make it tough you
know in both areas so - they're on
another level should the Chiefs have
traded Marcus Peters this offseason oh
because the team that he's on now is go
to the Super Bowl and obviously I'm not
giving him all the credit for that I'm
just saying a Chiefs team that was a few
man corners away or yeah just a few guys
in there I don't know it
yeah that's go it's a it's a very valid
question because if I'm a corner right
now I'm yelling up Kansas City and I'm
going I see what you have there and you
need me pal let's do this they just know
it's a more talent yes corners down to
right table for the end of the game
let's go it looked like they were
playing - man they were lining up in it
and they just don't have the jimmies and
Joe's to make the type of plays in the
back end to get them off the field to
win a football game and we saw that in
every loss they had this year it didn't
matter
oh we're up by 14 against the Chargers
yeah well there goes toll up forevers
gonna score 15 they'll ask you drivers
against the rims Gerald ever say find a
seam up against the Patriots oh we had
nobody to cover Gronk at the end he
caught two huge fades down the sideline
and big moments it just that was the
problem with their team all year and
they finally met the team that of course
had all the pieces in the right formula
to expose some of their issues I'm so
happy that mahomes played well I think
that this team he is so incredibly
talented that he took them far beyond I
thought what they were capable of what a
year for the Chiefs one of the most fun
teams I've ever got to watch I feel bad
for those guys and Kelsey and all them
I'm curious what Andy Reid does with Bob
Sutton I feel like it's getting kind of
towards the end for him I'm curious how
they attack free agency I'm saying if
I'm a corner I'm calling up the Chiefs
and the Colts and I'm saying let's go
win a Super Bowl
because I hear that that's a whole thing
those teams but I'm with you that's a
good thought there's no doubt Bill
Belichick has never poorly prepared for
a game I like
I feel like he's always there and I
think the thing about Andy and I feel
bad for Andy Reid but one of my friends
was asking me why I don't see Michael
Thomas as one of the elite guys and I
said if you're a receiver for Sean
Payton Kyle Shanahan or Sean McVeigh
Sean McVeigh Kyle Shanahan or Josh
McDaniels I knock you down a peg because
you're being put in a position that
other guys aren't and he said well what
about Andy Reid and I said Andy has all
the dressing but when push comes to
shove in the second half it's a man on
man game and a andy is trying to put his
guys in a position where Sammy Watkins
can outrun Jacy Jackson exactly right
and that's a leery offense it's not
about it's not about stacks and bunches
and creating space through pick plays at
the end of the game it's I believe that
I can put Kelsey on an island with a
linebacker and then he'll make the play
and that's and that's why I don't put
Amy reeds offense at that level no I I
agree it's not on that level they say
he's the next two year down no no I
think you're spot-on with that
assessment yeah at the end of the day
one of the great strengths of and
e-readers he's a great talent evaluator
and he gets those guys on his team and
then yes he tries to play a little bit
more what we would say matchup football
where he goes yep I'm just gonna put I
think my guys are better than your guys
and my guys gonna make a play
to where yes Belichick McVeigh Sean
Payton they're gonna go well no I'm
gonna put my guy who I really like in a
position that really screws with your
schematics and we're gonna try to abuse
that until you to just and then do
something else and that's probably where
the difference lies between you know the
guys you mentioned and that next tier of
offensive coordinator and my only other
grade with Andy is this Sean Payton
takes the shots man big balls Payton
Sean McVeigh showed us he's willing to
do it too when you know your defense
can't stop the Patriots
I'm keeping Patrick mahomes on the field
for a few of those fourth downs I am and
I think that's my one knock on Andy is
we know that the way you don't beat the
Patriots is going let's not make
mistakes
way you think the Patriots is by going
I'm gonna go crazy and Doug Peterson
showed that in the Super Bowl that if he
didn't go for that fourth down
Philly special if he didn't go for some
of the fakes and a little bit more risky
they wouldn't have won that game it's
the only way you beat that team is by
doing erratic things you know you got to
attack you got to do what they do they
keep the pressure on you all game long
they never let you die down
oh it's fourth and one we're gonna keep
our key offensive there we're gonna run
our D you know run our punt team out
there where you know luckily New England
called a timeout
the Chiefs had 12 players on the field
if you remember that remember that early
in the game that one you know that New
Englanders up calling timeout
the damn Chiefs mess it up but that
shows you the pressure that they put on
you throughout the game is enormous and
this is my last thing from this game
that I would say where I think this is a
last vital mistake and it started as the
first thing in the game and I think I
saw it said this on the podcast last
week if not I said it some other places
where I thought Kansas City made a
horrible mistake by not receiving the
ball to start the game they won the coin
toss I would have played and gone this
is our best unit I'm not gonna let Tom
Brady to tell anybody 9 minutes exactly
drive the ball down the field take all
the energy out of the stadium and now
put the pressure on my young quarterback
to have to answer that right from get-go
yeah I would have received the ball and
said no you're gonna have to deal with
mahomes magic right off the bat and see
if we can go down and score and dictate
a game that can be played the way that
she's wanted to play but that game was
always on Patriots terms it was until
very late where it became a little bit
of a shootout think about this first
drive was 15 plays 80 yards eight
minutes and five seconds touchdown that
second drive that they got the 44 even
though it ended in an interception 11
plays 43 yards and that play that took
six minutes so they took they took 14
minutes
they took nearly a quarter in their
first two possessions right that's and
and the cheese had the ball for two
minutes and it was on their terms the
entire time I completely agree the only
thing I'm gonna say is
for the Chiefs interception to get
called back by that bloody Ford offsides
if it's a referee thing if it's a missed
field goal it feels like that but for a
guy to be lined up that offsides after
he's had such a phenomenal year to
negate that interception which I feel
like would have given the Chiefs the win
yeah no I think that was that would have
been it I mean I don't think there's any
doubt about that you know and when I
watched it in real time I saw that he
was offsides and when I watched him real
times I thought who you know I kind of
gave Brady the benefit of doubt now so I
think Brady knew that the flag was
thrown but the wings on that play I
don't think he saw that flag he threw an
errand throat of his right and of course
there was high and got tipped in the air
and intercepted so hey even the all-time
greats need a little luck every now and
then and let's be honest - when Chris
Jones came around and smacked his
shoulder and they called a roughing the
passer on second and seven at their own
28 giving that first down
that was crazy that was a call - there's
no doubt about it
well especially when mahomes was hit a
very similar away right before in the
game and they hit him in the sense they
didn't call the flag right but hey I
always will say this I do feel like the
referees just watch their body
mannerisms when Drew Brees or Tom Brady
get hit they literally rush to them to
make sure that they're okay when they're
on the ground when the mahomes and
golf's got hit it's just like up well
you're young deal with it but it's
literally I feel like sometimes the
referees are like oh let me lay your
head on the ground drew don't don't hit
your head let me lay oh ho Tommy are you
okay like it does look that way on TV
for a guy who just loves football and
watches it like I do and I pay attention
to those little things where there's
like true concern every time those two
get hurt compared I see other guys where
they don't seem to care as much so the
stories that we're gonna hear a lot over
the next two weeks these are my left go
PR predictions we're going to hear all
about the 2001 Super Bowl that launched
the Patriots dynasty it's a rematch of
that game it's going to be the Battle of
coach
between Belichick and Sean McVeigh could
he this is when we deem Sean McVeigh the
guy that is this a passing of the torch
when I don't think Bella checks can be
done for five ten years frankly and I
think that it's going to be I think a
store lines gonna come out is how do
they take advantage of Marcus Peters and
his trash-talking I think will be
legendary on the Monday night of all the
media and all that stuff okay you know
Jared Goff and Tom Brady both California
kids will be a storyline the health of
Todd Gurley over the next two weeks will
be really big and I think the fact that
we're gonna hear from Brian Flores for
the first time before he goes down to
Miami will be very interesting I think
it's a very good matchup it's two
coaches that I think are gonna spend the
two weeks diving in but when I heard
that the opening line was Rams -1 I I
literally almost wanted to call ago I'm
gonna put five thousand on the Patriots
plus one wait you're saying the Patriots
I thought the Patriots were slight
favorites know they're underdogs
I'm gonna check right now when I heard
it first came out it was Rams but I'm
just gonna go to Vegas inside her and
see what they got
let me just check really quick I think
I'll being interested in the matchup
overall just my first base thought is I
worry about honey
started off apparently it started off as
a pick'em and now it's Patriots -2 and a
half so ok money
eighty-six percent of money right now
according to bet online 86% went on the
Patriots yeah hey listen I expected to
be an awesome game and the owner on the
over-under is 58 which would be
beautiful right right yeah it's uh this
is gonna be a good one
III you know I have no problem saying
that of course these were two of the
four best teams in football and yeah I
think down the stretch these were the
two best teams you know I understand the
Saints was debatable certainly but I
think New England clearly showed that
they were the best team in the AFC and
you know just a special player Mike
mahomes made the game a lot closer than
then I think a lot of other quarterbacks
wouldn't
all right one last non-playoff Super
Bowl thing just to end is this Carson
Wentz Eagle stuff I just want to touch
on it because this is my squad a few I
read the articles in the the big article
in the Philly voice where they talked to
about it said a half a dozen players on
the team that didn't want to be named
and a bunch of people in the
organization that had a number of
complaints about Carson Wentz mainly
saying that while he's incredibly
hardworking and determined and
intelligent he is selfish uncompromising
egotistical and so on that plays
favorites and doesn't want to be
questioned I read the entire article it
said how last year they had defillippo
and Reich that would rein him in and
that the big issue at the offense was
not the fact that they had all the
injuries and all that stuff and they
lost Reich and defillippo but it was
that Carson Wentz feels the need to
improvise and doesn't just want to run
the offense and these have been things
that we've heard a lot with Nick Foles
that he just wants to run the offense
where when spice he's better than foals
and because he believes he's better that
he should be doing more than just
running base training camp offense in
terms of favorites the entire team
apparently well from those guys it seems
like Jordan Matthews is back because
he's friends with Carson Wentz and the
reason Zach Ertz had all those catches
breaking the all-time record is because
whence would keep the ball more often
than not on the running place and throw
the check down to Earth's and then that
apparently upset the offensive line the
running backs and there was even a
blow-up around December in which one of
when the team was breaking down one of a
quote senior past catcher which I'm
gonna guess is al Shawn but I'm not
gonna say was asked to say what is
accountability and he responded nothing
so I'm just gonna take my left go two
cents here when Nick Foles came out with
those comments that I applauded saying
that the key of a quarterback is to not
feel above the team and that you should
be able to go to any offense and
defensive player and listen and feel
that I'm seeing the mess
now in what Nick Foles was saying to me
that that quote rings as a a note to
carson wentz and the thing is is Carson
Wentz has been built up to be amazing
and I believe he's super talented excuse
me
do I do I get upset that it's unnamed
players of course but it's clearly a
message that I think can ring true
there were times where I felt like he
was over targeting Zach Ertz I could say
how I asked this question why is Al
Shean all of a sudden getting the ball
and right and we've seen this there were
stages in Russell Wilson's career where
he was trying to do too much we've seen
it a little bit in DAX career when you
are in at Cam Newton's career a hundred
percent when you're a big athletic guy
and there are highlights of you that
exist on the Internet of you break in
three hundred pound sacks and make in
place and that you get rewarded and
applauded in the media for going above
and beyond you don't want to take the
check down but look what happens when
Nick did I believe that there's validity
to this story and I think the
interesting thing now for Carson Wentz
is gonna be you know how does he how
does he handle it but as an Eagles fan
I'm glad this is getting now because
this is the kind of story that I think
makes you go and look in the mirror and
makes you check your yeah I think this
is a good thing I do too
I think it's a good thing too it's just
it's gonna air laundry it's gonna make
Carson Wentz maybe you know
self-evaluate a little bit and and maybe
take some of these things into account
you know I think your your take on like
maybe Nick Foles was kind of speaking to
that I think that's a you know good job
by you connecting the tea leaves right
as we say yeah but no I you know they're
they're obviously with some things there
that were troubling just as factors you
know yeah hey we talked about the
offense seem different with Nick Foles
it was a little bit more traditional it
did bother me how much Carson Wentz was
always checking at the line of scrimmage
and doing things like that where I
wanted to be like what can we just get
up to the line of scrimmage
call a play sometimes does it always
have to be like I got to get us into the
exact perfect way oh this is the exact
perfect play for a two-yard gain like no
just don't
we also would say it's annoying how it
seems like the team is trying more but
also if I'm a past catcher or an
offensive lineman I'm gonna try more
when I know that you're running the
plays that are designed you know like
all of a sudden Alshon and and all these
guys are going I might get the ball this
time the offensive linemen are going
he's going to hand it off we're not just
gonna we're not gonna winch watch Wentz
roll around for 1 or 2 yard loss so it
all makes sense and I think that it's
it's the development of a young
quarterback but I also think that when
tis a good enough person that I don't
think he's gonna fight this
I think he's gonna learn from it I hope
so I mean Fletcher Cox and Brandon
Brooks have come out to file a basically
said no go all out of this stuff so hey
listen this is also - I just - things
and I'm done with this just as far as my
points one would be the best Eagles team
I still ever saw was the one with Carson
Wentz at a quarterback when he was on
his way to winning the NFL and he was
running the offense back then Simms yes
he certainly was now the other problems
- this is what happens when you're the
second pick of the draft no does
everybody is kissing your ass all the
time and this is where organizations
bite themselves in the ass with this
kind of crap because it's always like oh
oh good check Carson's check and oh oh
Carson yeah oh you know you're never
wrong Carson that's what happens because
he's their baby right that's how you
have to almost look at it they traded so
much for them they've hitched their
wagon to Carson Wentz as our franchise
quarterback and a lot of these cases
I've seen it happen with other players
that were on my team that got drafted in
you know high-end rounds or whatever it
may be
where yes accountability starts to get
thrown by the side because oh he's
talented and he was our guy and we
drafted him and now we're not going to
micromanage him like we do everybody
else and that's where the rest of the
team sees it and then it pisses them off
and then they start to go you know so
those are the issues I think we're
seeing kind of boil to the top here and
hopefully Carson Wentz does fix it
that was you said you had two things
well I meant to say though with two
things was though he was awesome that
was the best team that I ever saw and
that he was a second pick of the draft
it's incredible
Tom Brady the only quarterback who
didn't get sacked yesterday didn't get
sacked last week against the Chargers
Dantes karne Kia the Patriots that
machine going forward the Rams with
their high-priced corners defensive
lineman big free agent trades at wide
receiver stud at running back an
offensive mastermind and Shawn McVeigh
it's gonna be super super great I'm very
excited about the game Wednesday we're
going to do our film breakdown where
Sims is gonna watch the game he's only
got two
so those scheme films are gonna be super
in-depth we'll do our final bet which I
believe you've retaken the lead because
of that one game I might petition to
just get whoever you pick the other guy
I'm gonna pick but that'll be next week
and then again next week email us Sims
and left go at gmail.com there it's
packed but I would not say don't let
that discourage you email Josh we're
gonna have drink tickets for people I
believe we're gonna have big-name guests
some of the names that I'm already
hearing Sims and I I can't say anything
cuz josh is telling me I can't but all
timers like I know and I'm letting
everyone know this I'm not being Johnny
reporter this week this isn't this is
not like it was last year where we'd get
guests and we talked for eight minutes
we are we are gonna be able to get these
guys and just have a great time and I'm
super pumped about it man yeah me too
man it should be on sounds like we got a
great setup so it should be a good week
yeah all right for Sims without home in
it for pendrick good evening everybody
and for the lef koe Betty and for the
lef koe man we will holla holla holla at
you later man I can't believe we have
one game left why it's sad
I gotta watch basketball yes see you bud
so you did have a good day
[Music]